well we want to end tonight special with
a congratulations to one of our smartest
producers and one of our favorite people
Alex Pfeiffer works on this show he's a
reporter here he breaks a lot of the
stories you see puts together a lot of
the segments that make this show we
think worse worth watching tonight
Alex Pfeiffer proposed to his girlfriend
Jolie Friedman who is the kind of person
if you had a you know a son that age you
want your son to marry her she's that
great and thankfully she said yes we're
for marriage on the show and
particularly for the marriage of Alex
Pfeiffer and Jolie Friedman
congratulations it's wonderful